Hello! In today's Cloud Minute I'll be demonstrating
how to get help with gcloud
gcloud is the command line too that you use to access
and configure your Google Cloud Platform resources
If you are ever unsure how to use a gcloud command
just type the command followed by --help
This gives you some basic information about how
to use the command
For example this page says to use gcloud
followed by a group and then a command
a group and then a command.
And if I scroll down a little bit
I can see the different groups I can use with the gcloud command
One group pretty much everyone uses is config
Here's what the help looks like for config
And here you can see that the possible commands for config are
list
set
and unset
If I want to know how to use the list command I can type
gcloud config list --help
The help page says that there's a --all option
that will show me all the different properties
that I can set with gcloud config
So let's look at that
And now you can see all the different properties
that you can set with gcloud config
So if you are ever confused or stuck when using gcloud
try out the built in help
Thanks for watching
please check out some of our other Cloud Minute videos